horror movies are full of shocking
violence terrifying monsters and
occasionally hilarious bloopers like
these favorites we showed you last time
around sleep it hurt I'm sorry but there
are plenty more where those came from
here's a look at some more bloopers that
completely changed these horror movies
Fright Night the defining
characteristics of a vampire have
developed over more than a century of
fiction in film everybody knows they
sleep in coffins go out only at night
and have big fangs they used to puncture
their victims next to more effectively
drink their blood
countless vampire movies have featured
scenes of vampires dramatically exposing
those chompers but it loses its dramatic
effect and descends into silliness if
say those fangs were to spontaneously
fall out of an actor's mouth as
Christopher mintz-plasse discovered
while filming this scene for the 2011
Fright Night remake seriously warm
bodies part horror part comedy warm
bodies concerns a zombified young man
stumbling around and falling in love and
a kid's gotta eat so there are plenty of
zombie on human attack scenes here star
Nicholas Hoult is supposed to be going
after some human prey but he surprises
his co-star and crew with some goofing
off unleashing a loud boisterous
impression of one of the backwoods
torturers from deliverance a very
different kind of horror movie
Hostel part two Eli Roth's second hostel
is maybe even more gruesome than the
first so many disturbing things go down
murder torture power saws uses weapons
soccer played with a human head and all
kinds of gory stuff that makes going to
the movies such a magical experience and
yet the most unnerving thing to ever go
down in the movie the moment that will
linger with viewers for years to come is
this disturbingly funny outtake from
hostel part 2 where the victims don't
seem so sad after all disturbia the
terror of seeing a dead body is kind of
at the center of the entire horror genre
but if you're an actors scene festering
decaying bodies either dummies or actors
in makeup day in and day out takes the
sting out of it so really when a
snickering Shia LaBeouf approaches some
monstrosity on the set of disturbia and
kisses it he's just trying to jazz up
his workday Young Frankenstein finally
the Mel Brooks classic Young
Frankenstein isn't a horror movie itself
but it does perfectly skewer old
Hollywood horror movies comedian marty
Feldman is one of the film's many bright
spots portraying dr. Frankenstein's
faithful assistant I Gore is some
strange combination of maniac pet child
creep and vaudeville performer all those
parts come into play in equal measure
during this scene when Feldman gets a
little too carried away and tears apart
a prop with his teeth stop it it's gonna
be a long night so if you need any help
with the girls thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]